[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening everyone hope you all are
doing well
welcome to the table we are thrilled
that you're here and we're able to join
us uh all of our friends are online
we're thankful that you are able to
participate that way as well
so my name is don jacobs i'm one of the
uh on the leadership team here um here
at the table and i'm just going to kick
us off with
several announcements very important so
uh very important to kind of keep up
with we got a lot of stuff going on
it's because christmas is around the
corner and that just tends to kind of
make things a little bit busier for just
everyone across
everywhere what's going on just the
holiday season so anyway so one of the
biggest things that we just kind of set
up a tree just recently like
five minutes ago and so um that is for
uh salvation army um it's not make a
wish give me a second it is uh army a
salvation army uh it's an angel tree and
so it's kind of very similar to people
if you've had that kind of experience
where you go and you look avoid gifts
for for a kid there's like a list of
different things you can get for the
kids there's this check
a clipboard beside that where you can
put your name on which kid you're going
to
um or kids that you're you're planning
on doing that for and if you could bring
that back next week
um so
graham can kind of help coordinate some
of these things that's going on for for
this that's that would be fantastic if
not if you can reach out to graham
directly on how you're going to do that
drop off you need some extra time and
then even starvation army has some
additional drop-off places where you can
kind of do that so but next week would
be great if you can get that together
in that kind of time frame
so a second announcement um so one of
our members um is also according to
coordinating with another church um so
they have a friend from that's a refugee
from
afghanistan who is expecting and so um
which is can't all in itself brings on a
kind of stress so they were wanting to
bring be able to just shower this family
with diapers um as many many diapers
they possibly can and so we're going to
try and partner with them
so we do that so you can even drop off
diapers um this week next week uh just
whenever you possibly get that uh be
able to
get that taken care of that'll be
awesome and you can breed them here
nancy can also
give her direct messaging
or send her cash there's information if
you're part of the at the table
facebook group that's on our main page
but it's just more of a one word with
directly with our members there's
details and information that you take
out take a look out for there
and then one other last thing
just been on your radar
is that we are having a
youth holiday hangout
that's going to happen on december the
5th so that is for all of our youth who
are in grade 7th through 12th
it's going to be here at the table um
and it's going to be starting about 6
45-ish
to kind of kind of hang out here and
just kind of do some fun new things so
with all of that information
that's a lot um do make sure you check
check out our facebook page um as well
because we're gonna always post a lot of
stuff on there for you guys to kind of
keep up with with things that are coming
up um it's going to be a lot of stuff
over the next several weeks especially
as we gear up towards christmas
so with that i'm going to start off with
a prayer
lord thank you so much for uh just
bringing us together
thank you for um making the space
where we can just come here
um be able to just sit
here at your feet
to be able to tune in to listen
and to what you have for us tonight
i pray that you help us to just engage
with you
during worship i pray you open up our
hearts and minds to what brett has to
share with us tonight
and i pray that you just um give us and
equip us with the tools that we need for
tackling the things that we are just
dealing with
every day in christ and i pray amen
amen thanks don
all right you guys y'all stand with us
cause we are gonna get started a little
differently than we normally do and that
we're seeing a song
that um it's kind of maybe more like
performancy you know what i mean like
it's a song that you would kind of jam
out to on the radio not necessarily one
you would expect to communally sing
together but it's a great vibe and we
need your energy to join in with us on
the song
if you've ever listened to high women
before i was introduced to them by a
friend and they're kind of like this you
know girl power
full country
thing going on
it's interesting
but
the values that they're talking about in
the song are definitely values that line
up with our community so y'all just
enjoy it with us and if you want to
we're just gonna you know maybe clap
along give us some love and um then
we'll keep on going through the worship
set all right
let's see i'm gonna count us off to get
us started
[Music]
i can be a
if
[Music]
in a oh
is
[Music]
happiness
let us
is
[Music]
with a crowded table
and a place
by the fire
for
every i
shall take
on the world
and able
and bring us back together
when the day
is
[Music]
nice you guys thank you
awesome
all right maggie
[Music]
god we just
open our hearts up to you right now
and i ask that
we could come honestly before you in
this place
that our worship would rise from honesty
and truth
so wherever we've been today whatever
you've been going through
however you might be feeling even right
now being in this service maybe your
mind is distracted or maybe you come
with burdens maybe you come with baggage
i just invite you to just be honest
and i just think of the scripture where
jesus
spoke
to that woman and said
the true worshipers will worship in
spirit and truth
so let's just come before god right now
with truth
be where we are and acknowledge where he
is because he's not far from us
he's with us
i love you lord
[Music]
will your mercies never fail me
and all my days
i've been held in your hand
from the moment that i wake up
until i lay my head
i will sing
of the
goodness of god
and all my life you have been faithful
and all my life you have been so
so
good
with every breath that i am able
i will sing
of the
goodness of god
i love your voice
you have led me through the fire
in darkest nights
you are close like no mother
i've known you as a father
i've known you as a friend
and i will sing
of the
goodness of god
all my life
and all my life you have been faithful
in all my life you have been so
so
good
with every breath that i am able
i will sing
of the goodness of god
your goodness
it's is after me
your goodness is running after it's
running after me
with my life laid down i surrender now
and
[Music]
it's running after me
oh my life you have been faithful
[Music]
and all my life you have been so
so
good
with every breath that i am able
i will sing
of the
goodness of god
yes i will sing
of the goodness of god
of the goodness
of god
[Music]
you guys please join in with us as we go
through our prayers of the people and if
you're online
please feel free to leave a comment
participate with us
there jesus for the city of saxi texas
and for every city and community and all
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve
[Music]
and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
so now we lift up these names and
situations
[Music]
from online nancy's chemo treatments
vivian and karen and protection for
those who are traveling during
thanksgiving in the parkers
[Music]
also online
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence god
blessing all the
[Music]
blessed are the tears of all
once more
brave enough to show the lord their
scars
[Music]
blessed on the earth
the kingdom is
the yours
is yours
[Music]
hold on a little more this is
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
even in the face of great abuse
blessed are the deeds that go
[Music]
blessed are the ones who fight for
justice
longing for the coming day of
the peace that thirsts for righteousness
[Music]
welcoming the last
the
kingdom is yours
hold on a little
[Music]
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
the kingdom is yours
the
kingdom is yours
[Music]
this is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
[Music]
are the ones who suffered
to love
[Music]
the
kingdom is yours
the kingdom is
on a yours
more this is not the end
hope is in the lord keep your eyes on
him
the kingdom
is yours
the kingdom is yours
on a little more
this is
[Music]
is
jesus would our eyes stay on you
in the difficult moments
where we're losing our cool
where the pressure becomes too great and
sadness is so strong
where we struggle with our own
insecurities and egos
or our own addictions
and obsessions
with things outside of your character
and nature and kingdom
would our eyes turn and fix on you god
would our hearts
be in a posture that is open to your
touch
would you re-center and refocus us
would you surround us with your love and
grace
god would we have
your nature
flowing through us
would it be the way that we talk to our
families and our friends would it be the
way that we serve our co-workers at our
jobs would it be the way that we
interact with people in our daily lives
would the character of god be present in
us
and would it give us hope god
would it be our foundation
our rock
would it lift us up out of muck and mire
and put our feet on a mountain
would you give us a solid place to stand
when everything around us
is shaky
would we know that we are yours
would we know that we are loved
and would we love others from that place
god
you are good
and we fix our eyes on you tonight
amen
thank you guys so much for worshiping
with us if y'all want to be seated and
turn and say hello to the people around
you brett's going to come up and get us
started with the message
all right well good evening everyone
grace and peace
super good to uh just to be with all of
you um my name is brett i'm the
pastor here and um i want to
welcome all of you but uh particularly
those uh who are new
so so glad to have you with us and uh
those who are joining us online love you
lots as always you are not forgotten you
are not second-class citizens at the
table
we uh we love you just the same and
we're so um so glad that you could be
with us um we have um for such a small
community we have a really like cool
kind of online group there we have a
meetup that's exclusively online
we have folks who are on every sunday um
and so that's it's it's really really
cool that was one i think kind of hidden
blessing of kovit is that we took
something that would we wouldn't have
attempted that for probably years um but
that kind of pushed us to do that and i
know people have found us you know
because of of that um which is really
cool so
um at any rate i'm uh yeah i'm just i'm
really grateful to be with you all
tonight so we are in let's see this is
part five um in our series titled first
peter
um where we are of course walking
through that entire book
and um
so
the title of my message tonight is reset
reset and uh we're gonna be covering
kind of a big section it'll be verses 17
through 25
um so we're gonna read it i encourage
you to kind of think of it i don't know
as like scripture reading meditation
like try to stay focused logged in it's
just one of those that you know it's
long enough we're about halfway through
the mind starts to drift you know um so
i encourage you to kind of follow along
and uh and then we'll we'll kind of jump
in here so um beginning in verse 17 of
first peter chapter
one
since you call on a father
who judges each person's work
impartially
live out your time as foreigners here in
reverent fear
for you know
that it was not with perishable things
such as silver or gold that you were
redeemed from the empty way of life
handed down to you from your ancestors
but with the precious blood of christ a
lamb without blemish or defect
he was chosen before the creation of the
world but was revealed in these last
times for your sake through him you
believe in god who raised him from the
dead and glorified him and so your faith
and hope are in god verse 22 now that
you have purified yourselves by obeying
the truth so that you have sincere love
for each other love one another deeply
from the heart
i love that line love one another deeply
from the heart you can kind of hear him
imploring them to you know it's not even
just like the general kind of you know
love each other love one another um
that's lots of times in the bible love
one another love one another but it's
like he's really trying to like i'm like
i'm for real you know love one another
deeply from the heart verse 23 for you
have been born again not of perishable
seed but of imperishable through the
living and enduring word of god for all
people are light grass
all their glory is like the flowers of
the field the grass withers the flowers
fall but the word of the lord endures
forever and this is the word that was
preached to you
so if you were um here for the very
first message in this series you might
um have kind of noticed that peter
he basically ends this chapter
much where he began it um and so here's
they want to give you the opening words
for those who weren't here here's the
opening words of the book of first peter
it begins like this to god's elect
exiles scattered throughout the
provinces so it's that the key word
there is exiles right what we kind of
talked about is you might kind of hear
that word
um and kind of think like oh okay
interesting so apparently he's writing
this letter to like kind of foreigners
or you know people who aren't from that
area they're they're exiled from their
own country maybe it was i don't know
was it civil war like what's going on
here um but if you're here for that
first message you know that um that's
actually not the case he's writing to
people that for all scholars can tell
these are folks who um
they grew up in that area so they're
like not exiles
um and that of course is peter's point
right he's saying um
you don't forget basically that you are
strangers in a strange land right
basically he's reminding them of their
baptism because they are um what was at
that time the largest empire in the
world they're part of the roman empire
and that's a it's a powerful culture um
and so kind of what we named in the
first message was like
all of us have really drunk deeply at
the waters of our culture but we haven't
even realized the degree to which that's
true
uh you've probably had this experience
where um like you didn't realize you had
a culture until you go and visit a
different culture i'm sure some of you
had this experience right you go and all
of a sudden you realize oh wow
okay huh didn't realize that i had a
culture didn't realize like all like
it's the million and one things right
they just take for granted um
and what he's naming is not that like
your culture is just all terrible and
evil and you know so you're you know be
strangers and foreigners um i don't
think it's it's necessarily that extreme
he's just saying like be aware like
remember your first allegiance your
first commitment your first identity it
is with christ right so he's so he
starts there with this language of elect
now here's the opening that we just read
verse 17. since you call on a father who
judges each person's work impartially
live out your time as foreigners here in
reverent fear all right can you see the
kind of connection with exiles in verse
one and now here where he's talking
about foreigners so he's kind of ending
much where he um began
so um this is kind of where i want to
start i want to give you kind of the big
idea up front so if you're a note taker
you can jot this down
for many christians
america
has replaced the church
for many christians america has replaced
the church um you you might say
um that it's it's almost like i don't
know maybe like if america america is
like the sun
around kind of which
we all sort of revolve
you know um
in other words it's almost like we're
just very kind of centered on america
american society american culture
we're slightly obsessed with america i'd
say
obsessed with america's potential
obsessed with america's kind of problems
obsessed with america's history
um
this is the thing that kind of fills our
days and our conversations and our you
know twitter feeds and
just all of the thing right this is you
click on the news of course and
it's sort of the you know it's like the
latest
rise and fall and you know all the all
the things of of american american
society
and um
and i think
this can become problematic for um for
christians and i think this actually can
kind of play out
on both the
kind of political right and the
political left i think right now on the
political right it's very very and i'm
talking not just about the political
right i'm really talking about
christians tonight right christians on
the political right um
are
i mean it's just it's it's somewhat um
it's a little more obvious i'd say we'll
get to in a minute um the the christian
kind of left and how it plays out there
but on the right um
yeah you know i mean how does it play
out like
it's it's almost like i've even heard
this language sometimes like america i
heard someone say america is the light
of the world
um that of course is matthew 5 language
that jesus jesus said that a version of
that he just didn't say america right he
said you are the you are the light of
the world the city set on a hill
right and he's talking about like you
know the people of god you know he's
talking about his disciples like you are
the city center hill you're the light of
the world and can you see how it's like
it's just a little modification you know
it's kind of like oh that's scripture
you know well
kind of it just you kind of took it and
you said
instead of the you you kind of interpret
it right in a certain way and so all of
a sudden it's you know america is kind
of the light of the world america is the
you know the city set on a hill
um this really kind of becomes even
america is really kind of god's chosen
people
you know almost the new israel
um so to speak
uh almost you could even think of it
like george washington was like you know
he was like moses
leading the people you know um this is
this is a thing right i mean some of you
i don't know if you think i'm being
really extreme right now but i think
most of you know i'm i'm not making
things up right like this is this is a
real issue right now um for um for
christians and i think you know the
primary problem with it um well there
are many but i think in the end it's
just a it's like a bad reading of the
bible you know it's just jesus didn't
say america is the city settlement he
didn't he didn't say that and so we need
to be really careful about well our big
idea right kind of replacing the church
with america
um
all right so that's the political right
i think it's a little bit more subtle
on the the political left i will you'll
notice anytime i talk politics i'll
always try to offend everyone
i try to that's always my goal you know
um some people tell me you shouldn't get
political and i think usually what they
mean by that is you shouldn't get
partisan
you know and that i would agree with
like i think it's you got to be really
careful about preachers getting all
partisan and like what's the problem
we're talking about tonight where you
start to align the kingdom of god with a
particular political party right and now
the new kingdom is coming through
such and such candidate like
that starts to get me nervous you know
um so i agree i don't want to be
partisan but i think the gospel though
is deeply political i mean you heard you
heard peter tonight right like exiles
foreigners
right he's he's he's talking he's kind
of hitting at a certain mode of being in
the world right a way that we think of
ourselves as political people
right um
so okay that's my caveat let's get back
to the all right so the left how does
this play i think it's more subtle i
think partly because um even some
christians left right now are often kind
of criticized as being you know
unpatriotic um because there is a kind
of a more of a tendency to point out and
name
the less than
stellar history of america in some
respects you know that's putting it
mildly everything from whether it's the
treatment of indigenous peoples
to slavery of course
ongoing issues with racism and i mean
it's just right so so christians will
you know kind of point out and can kind
of be um criticized as maybe you know
being unpatriotic um
so you might you know think like what's
you know that's not
so this isn't that issue that's the
right that's the christian right and
that's their issue um but here's the
thing i still notice i think we still
kind of circle though you know it's like
we're still kind of um
real obsessed
um
still our feeds you know
our eyes are kind of glued to the tv
glued to the social media streams
um our lives are filled with the drama
you know of american politics and um and
then you know there's some frustration i
think we can get real
frustrated i see my my friends on the
the left christian left you know getting
real frustrated at america for not um
not acting christian
you know it's like come on people you
gotta be christian
like act like jesus you know and um
that's where i think we get a little bit
kind of off you know it's a little
unrealistic um
uh well let me give you i'll give you an
example this is um
the uh left-leaning uh christian
preacher activist writer jim wallace
um he's by the way i love a lot of what
he's he's done in the world um
he wrote a book it was titled um god's
politics why the right gets it wrong and
the left doesn't get it
and uh it kind of strikes me as
i mean honestly i love the quote except
for just a little adjustment a little
tweak he makes it's the tweet we were
talking about earlier that if you ask
the question who is wallace
talking to
who is his audience who's the who's the
we who's the us
who's the you
now if in this quote he was speaking
right to the church
then i would say yes and amen my friend
preach it and we'll read the quote in
just a second um
but it's because he
if you listen closely he's not actually
speaking to the church he's speaking to
american society as a whole
that's that's i think the interesting
thing so let's um
go ahead and read this
most of the biblical prophets he writes
whom we pass over week after week in our
congregations would offer a quite
searing indictment of contemporary
american society
specifically that we have become a
nation of endangered souls
and that our society and our politics
are governed by values quite foreign to
the heart of our religious traditions
how does a nation of endangered souls
recover an authentic faith that is true
to the gospel the example of jesus the
witness of the prophets and the crushing
needs of our
time
can you hear some of the language did
you did you notice um how it's you know
our our
our soul is in danger
we're losing
right our faith
and we're not being faithful to the
values that brought us to this point
we've got to recover our christian faith
right in other words while wallace in
his politics he would
be very different from his christian
brothers and sisters on the political
christian right
but can you see the kind of shared the
shared assumption there
um
that
well it's it's exactly what we named
right for many um
christians america and american society
has effectively replaced the church
really america is the new people of god
and so even our prophetic kind of words
we direct not to the church
um but we direct to
the kind of society as
as a whole
now okay so why am i saying all of this
is my point to um
i don't know
just to stir the pot or something
or bash america i don't know however
people might be interpreting this um no
i think i'm just naming it because i
think peter named it
right because to a church embedded in
the roman empire at that time
he looked at them and he said remember
don't forget
you are exiles and foreigners
here
you are strangers in a strange
land don't forget
that you have a new identity
and so before
you are filling the blank before you are
american before you are for his audience
it would be roman but before you are
whatever it is texan you know i don't
know all of our weird categories right
our all of our cultures before you are
that what is he naming he's aiming
remember you have been his language was
bought with the precious blood of jesus
christ he's saying you are sons you are
daughters of the living god and you've
got to start there right he's really
reminding them of their baptism
why because
caesar
is
not
lord
jesus
is
lord
and america
is not the lord
and america is not the last best hope of
the world
that's
in the in the church we don't use that
kind of description of our countries
right
like because jesus is the last best hope
of the world and it's his kingdom right
as we're singing the kingdom is yours
god
not ours
it's not our little political project
that we get to call the shots and
determine how the kingdom of god will go
right
i'm not the lord ether neither are you
right the kingdom is yours god
this is about you and your agenda and
what you're up to in the world
so i think um
all this kind of leads me to the place
of saying you know what i think
and i saw actually was after i'd written
this message but i saw the the short
video clip i linked to it in my e-letter
this week um for the five of you that
read it
there's um i linked it in my e-letter
and
um
i'm just joking i know more people read
than five but um
but it was a video this is and again
i've picked on everyone so but i'm gonna
this was i think real egregious so it
was uh
from it was a church in san antonio
maybe some of you saw the clip and it
was in a christian church and they were
chanting let's go brandon
right which of course is kind of this
way of saying like bleep biden right
like sort of the way
um
now that's the picture that's kind of
what i'm talking about that's a picture
of a of a church that has really it's
losing its way
right it's it's starting to forget
that
that america is not the church and
america is not the kingdom of god and
america is not the lord jesus is the
lord and we're submitted to him
and that's what it means to be the
church right
um
so this really i mean you know this this
plays out in really um
i mean really powerful ways and so i
want us i think in the end what we kind
of need is a bit of a of a reset as
christians in this country i think and
especially in the church right we kind
of need to we need to
we need a bit of a theological reset so
i want to do is give you three steps
tonight to a theological
reset
that was the world's longest
introduction
to my point so three
three steps to a theological reset
number one um we need to remember our
true story we need to remember our true
story
verse 18 peter wrote for you know that
it was not with perishable things such
as silver or gold that you were redeemed
from the empty way of life handed down
to you from your ancestors but with the
precious blood of christ a lamb without
blemish or defect he was chosen before
the creation of the world but was
revealed in these last times for your
sake through him you believe in god who
raised him from the dead and glorified
him and so your faith and your hope are
in
god what's he getting at with all that i
think he's he's the language i've been
using is he's reminding them of their
baptism right he's reminding them of who
they are
and in the fact that um your story
is bigger than the american story
right and now why does language of story
matter because story is about identity
right whoever controls your story the
story you tell about yourself about
yourself in your head
like whatever that story is that
powerfully shapes who you are so so the
church is a community where our story
doesn't begin with well i am an american
and these are my american values and
these are my american politics and this
is these are my american
thoughts right in philosophy of living
but we first and foremost we start with
we are
christians
i am
a disciple of jesus christ right so he's
he's kind of trying to um i think
reinforce and and shift and we need this
shift to just remember again
um our story
and what is that story you know it
really is kind back in the last week
like our story is that when we were lost
in our disordered and crazy desires
when we were making an absolute mess
of
our life
and our families and our community that
like right then christ died for us
and christ brought us up out of the pit
he set our feet on a solid rock and now
he's given us a new identity a new
trajectory in life a new hope
right a a whole a new legacy for
ourselves and our families in like
generations like that's our story
like that's where we begin right that's
that's bedrock is i know that i know
that i know that i'm loved
and i'm known
and then i'm brought into a people into
the church into a community where we
collectively live out that story
together
right that's your story
that's your story and only secondarily
do you begin to get into all the other
stories of your life and there are many
right of all sorts of thoughts and ideas
and cultures and things that you've been
um a part of
right um so that's first that's kind of
the first step i think we need to just
remember um our story
second second step in our theological
reset is that we need to be faithful to
and faithful in discipleship to jesus
and then learn to love our brothers and
sisters in christ well this is that
verse 22 that i harped on earlier now
that you have purified yourselves by
obeying the truth so that you have
sincere love for each other
love one another deeply from the heart
i love um
that he
well i'll just say it's interesting that
he doesn't kind of remind them of their
story
and then say and get out there
and change the world
or get out there and save the world
instead what does he do he reminds them
of their story and their identity
and then he says love one another deeply
from the heart
i think um i think this is there's so
much wisdom here because honestly
until
we can love the people around us the
person to your left or your right or in
front of you or behind you right now
like if we can't love the people in our
meetups our small groups
um
i'm not sure
we're ready to like get out there and
change the world right it's sort of like
almost uh
maybe let's like ride the the bike
around the block before we go biking
across america you know
and and honestly i'm right there with
you i'm not putting this on you as like
a condemnation like you don't even love
each other you know it's like it's hard
it's it's hard to stay married
you know like it's hard to raise
children it's hard to have friends and
actually have those relationships like
last for a while it's hard to be at a
church and not move on every like two
years you know like it's it's really
challenging to love one another deeply
from the heart i love um
this is a quote from my beloved
dostoyevsky who i quote way too much but
i'm gonna keep doing it because i don't
care and uh this is from the brothers
karamazov he says the more i love
humanity in general the less i love man
in particular
and by the way this is um he's writing
like the 1860s so forgive the sexist
language in my dreams i often make plans
for the service of humanity and perhaps
i might actually face crucifixion if it
were suddenly necessary
and yet i am incapable of living in the
same room with anyone for two days
together i know from experience as soon
as anyone is near me
his personality disturbs me and it
restricts my freedom in 24 hours i begin
to hate the best of men one because he's
too long over his dinner another because
he has a cold and keeps on blowing his
nose i become hostile to people the
moment they come close to me
but it has always happened that the more
i hate men individually the more i love
humanity
[Laughter]
isn't that insightful
right
his name almost and i think what's
interesting is at times even looking
back in my own life the times i have
talked the
biggest game
i'm gonna change the world we need to
change the world is often when i was
struggling the most
to like love the people around me
think it's exactly what he's name and
this is why i think peter is right on
with
look church remember who you are and
then just start with love one another
deeply from
the heart
right learning to love people in
particular not the idea of people not
people in the abstract humanity but like
actual
people
that's hard
isn't it amen it's hard
but that's where discipleship happens
that's where we start to work it out
that's where the kingdom of god happens
in relationship right as we actually try
to relate to one another
and um
not
not let it end in hating each other
that's how we make it work
all right so that's the second step
um faithful and discipleship loving our
brothers sisters and christ will and
third we need to remember that christ
endures
not human political
projects
for he says all people are like grass
and that word people i would just add
all the human things
every every human project every
institution
um culture
all this like it just all people they're
like grass their glory is like the
flowers of the field right because it
can be beautiful
right culture can be beautiful um
nations can be at times and sometimes
terrible but sometimes beautiful
but ultimately it's like the flowers
right
it's just
the flowers the field the grass they
just wither the flowers fall verse 25
but the word of the lord endures forever
and this is the word that was preached
to you in the new testament of course
the word
of god who's the word of god if you know
the gospel of john you know jesus is the
word the revelation the communication of
god
and i think it's just so easy that we
start to put our hope in people in in
human oh so human institutions
and we either start to get kind of
caught up in an idealized kind of
version of them like yes this can be it
this can be the kingdom of god
or once that fails then we reverse track
and then we get bitter
right
and and i think he's kind of showing us
a better way that we just stay centered
on christ like don't put your hope
your deep faith
in people or human political projects
don't go there like stay centered on
christ he won't fail you
the people around you
like at times will hurt you and fail you
that's just the reality heck even the
table at some point i guarantee you if
you're here long enough you will get
hurt and offended probably maybe some of
you are offended tonight who knows right
like it's
this is just what it means to be human
so this is why he's saying remember like
ground yourself root yourself in this
remember it's christ who endures
not human political projects and
honestly i think kind of coming back to
the whole theme of america and such i
think this can actually give us a much
healthier relationship to america
because when we're like relying on
america to like bring in the kingdom
you know then we're either idealizing
her and being very
kind of somewhat silly about what she's
actually capable of or we're super
hacked off because she's not living up
to the ideals right like i think we need
to kind of take off
these um i think if it was like we were
talking to a therapist
they'd probably say that these ideals of
like america can be the kingdom america
can be the lord you know it's probably
what he would call or the therapist he
or she might call a um unrealistic
relational expectation
right just to like don't put that on
america
america's not she's beautiful and
terrible and everything in between like
just human
right don't put that
don't don't do that with human
institutions not even the table
you know in the end we turn our eyes to
christ
all right let me pray for you
lord jesus um
how quickly we
venerate and lift up other lords
how quickly we turn our gaze
and put our faith in our trust in other
kingdoms
but lord only you and your kingdom
endure
so help us remember who we are
our story
help us learn to love our families and
our brothers and sisters in christ
before we launch with hubris into saving
the world
help us keep our gaze fixed on you the
only one who endures forgive us for
confusing human institutions with your
rule in reign may your kingdom come may
your will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
in the name of the father the son
and the holy spirit
amen
all right we're going to close with an
old hymn
and as we sing it together there is a
lot of old language in it so these and
thousands stuff that you normally don't
hear us
using around here but what i love about
it instead of us trying to transform it
into something that sounds much more
modern and current
is uh the reminder that
this same prayer these words
have been
said before
a long time ago
and this problem that we have sometimes
of losing our way and our focus and
forgetting who
should be our rock who should be our
centering
line
this isn't a new problem this is
something that we're always returning
back to
in human culture
um so if you guys will just join with us
and um let this be a prayer for us to
return
to the vision that god originally has
set in front of us to love like brett
was talking about tonight
all right
[Music]
be
thou my vision
oh lord of
my heart
[Music]
not be
allowed
[Music]
waking
thy
presence my life
[Music]
i ever
thee
[Music]
heaven
my
victory one
may i reach
heaven's choice
[Music]
whatever
before still be
my vision
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
if you are visitors to this church we
just want to say thank you
um there is a way that we just want to
know that you came and just we want to
have a record and even just say it thank
you to to you if you wouldn't mind there
is a little note card on the back table
when you first walk out of this
sanctuary do you mind filling that out
um
for us so we can have just have a record
and we also just want to say thank you
for being here
um also if you are
um
if you're wanting to give financially to
support the ministry uh you can do that
online there's also a box as well
for you able to make that um donation as
well
of course anything that you um
if you're needing prayer
or anything that just kind of resonated
with you tonight i would be happy to
pray with you and i'll be up here for
anybody that just is looking for that
and then just to send you off
i'm just going to read this benediction
for you
you are not what you have
or the things you possess
you are not what you do
or what others do
for you or your occupation
you're not what other people say about
who you are
however you are a child of god
and no one can take that away
there's nothing you can do
to make god love you less or more
you uh nor do you have to hurry or worry
just trust in jesus because he loves you
you can rest in god's love and let your
kindness be gift to others
so go and share in the love of christ
with other people
thank you have a good night
[Music]
what will you do with each of them
what will you do with your
wild life
[Music]